we're making Vietnamese Nook mum butter
it's a butter baby I woke up and chose
violence today so let's make some fish
sauce butter to feed my family for
breakfast everyone loves fish sauce and
toast right it's Amazon Prime day and I
got this stand mixer on sale so I've
been in a menacing mood lately but let
me show you how to make this after
turning your own butter you're left with
butter and buttermilk save the
buttermilk for pancakes later right now
you can season your butter with anything
you'd like like I said earlier I'm
feeling a little silly I made this mum
syrup to mix into my butter to get that
big Umami cake we all love I topped it
with some fresh Thai chilies and lime
juice to get the full complex flavor and
then finished it over Wings because my
dad got mad about the toast